over the last 3000 years
we've been experientially studying
consciousness
and metaphysics only recently
since the scientific revolution has a
global paradigm
of materialism become dominant
industrialization has connected billions
of people
to electricity and the internet plus
much more the revelation of quantum
mechanics blew our minds
and now the 21st century is knocking
how can science possibly probe
the most primal question of our
existence
what is consciousness
[Music]
if you'll join me for a moment in a game
i'd like to ask you to close your eyes
and imagine you are in bed
dozing off you
immediately begin dreaming that you're
in a kitchen
pouring yourself some tea
you're adoring the high quality
of this full immersion where you can
literally even smell the aroma
you accidentally spill a little and
suddenly you snap back to laying
in your bed with your eyes closed
now you can open your eyes what you
just experienced we predict
is a microcosm reflecting
the macrocosm in other words
the same way we dream a reality
and take a first-person perspective
is precisely what we are doing with this
reality one
indivisible infinite consciousness
in a dream fully immersed
in the high quality completely
forgetting it is a dream
why we see people running around seeking
objects relationships substances
anything is because they want
to pierce the veil of separation
to feel whole
the irony is you
already are what you seek
[Music]
you